hi i'm eric boss and there's one
underappreciated scene from avengers end
game that i just really love we go back
we get the stones before thanos gets
them
thanos doesn't have the stones that's
not how it works well that's what i
heard wait but who
star trek terminator time cop time after
time
basically any movie that deals with time
travel die hard
no it's not one this is known think
about it if you travel to the past
that past becomes your future and your
former present
becomes the past so back to the future
is a bunch of [ __ ]
in screenwriting this is an example of
what we call hanging a lantern when the
logic of your story is a bit murky or
retreading on a familiar trope you just
hang a lantern on it by calling it out
with a joke through scott lang the end
game writers are saying
yes we are aware back to the future
exists just to go with us
on this but i have to take issue with
them calling back to the future [ __ ]
because
it's one of my all-time favorite films
and to date i believe it handles the
tricky narrative device of time travel a
lot better than any film including
avengers game join me on this comparison
of two films that i love avengers
in-game and back to the future
specifically by how each film
handles time travel both films approach
time travel in a similar way
and that going back in time causes split
alternate historical timelines and that
the future can be either changed or
restored but
endgame differs in a key way rather than
suggests changes to the past ripple
affect the future
erasing people from existence when their
parents don't hook up and whatnot
endgame applies theoretical physics to
the equation changes to the past now
cause new parallel
timelines to branch off while the
original timeline remains
unchanged so despite committing to a
fresh more
scientifically grounded approach to time
travel why isn't the time travel and
avengers 10 game the thing everyone
celebrates as its greatest narrative
triumph
well it might be because the filmmakers
of in-game never set out to make a time
travel movie directors joe and anthony
russo bristle when they're asked about
the time travel logic of the film and
the screenwriters marcus mcfeely
revealed in an interview
that time travel was actually marvel had
kevin feige's insistence
there's a reason the screenwriters and
directors give wildly different
interpretations when asked whether cap
grew old in an alternate timeline or
within this timeline the time travel
logic in the film was an
assignment that they had to figure out
not a point of
inspiration that they always dreamed of
exploring by comparison back to the
future was inspired by screenwriter bob
gale finding his father's old yearbook
and
imagining interacting with his father as
a younger man now gail leaves out the
part about hooking up with his mom but
either way
this was time travel which fulfillment
from its fortune the madness back to the
future's time travel comes from one
place
the mind of dr emmett brown he is our
constant of this film when we're
confused he shouts a crackpot
explanation at us to set us straight
despite doc brown being a scientist the
time travel of this film is presented as
fantasy not science fiction it leaves
the precise inner workings of time
travel a mystery hidden in the mystical
flux capacitor
a magical device that doc brown
conceived of through a stroke of divine
intervention when he struck his head on
a bathroom sink
endgame on the other hand shows
insecurity when it comes to time travel
logic there's no one authority on the
subject in the film scott lang
accidentally experiences it but he
doesn't understand it the scientists
tony stark and bruce banner try to
explain it using the language of
theoretical physics but really it's the
ancient one and dr
strange who are the experts cause they
possess the time stone and they seem to
have the deepest understanding of how it
works and they're not scientists they're
sorcerers so is time travel in the mcu
magic or is it science is it fantasy or
science fiction without clear answers to
these questions too much of the plot
gets bogged down in exposition and time
travel mechanics
endgame's epic final battle is
interrupted with a clunky debate over
where the hell to go next what do you
want me to do with this damn thing
get those stones as far away as possible
no
we need to get them back where they came
from no way to get him back thanos
destroyed the quantum tunnel
hold on that wasn't our only time
machine
this exchange exposes how until this
moment this battle really had no focus
it was just one side clashing into
another side now the battle becomes a
game of rugby as they try to rush the
stones to a
van with a time machine in it is that
really the most compelling goal
and to be honest before i reminded you
that's what the sequence is about did
you even remember
i've seen this movie a but ton of times
and even i forget maybe it's because
thanos simply wrecks their goal line and
has no narrative consequence because
banner just builds another quantum
tunnel at the end of the movie it's
clear that the filmmaker's hearts in the
finale were
in stark's sacrifice and they just kind
of worked backward from there they did
the same with cap they've said that they
always intended on cap ending up back in
the 40s getting his dance with peggy but
because their boss wanted time travel to
be in the story
and because they never really settled on
the exact math of how time travel
operates they shifted cap's entire
journey back to peggy
off screen we have a general sense of
how we got there but we didn't see it
so instead cap's big run back to his
girl
the run that every famous romantic film
story highlights as its climax
it never happens it's just kind of like
an afterthought compare this
to marty and his true love no not
jennifer
doc is marty's best friend yes it's
weird that a teenager
has an 80 year old man as his best
friend and this weird relationship has
given us plenty of laughs as the duo
they inspired rick and morty but in the
final minutes of back to the future
after marty seemingly achieves his goal
of returning to 1985 we're not done yet
because marty's elderly boyfriend is
about to get shot by libyan terrorists
marty has spent the entire movie trying
to warn doc and now we get to see
michael j
fox sprinting through city streets
rolling down a [ __ ] hill
just to get back to his man now the
whole point of this final charge is to
remind marty that despite his victory he
remains a slave to the ticking clock
as we all do and that ticking clock in
my view is the one thing great time
travel stories require
but in-game fully lacks time travel
stories are about time itself how we are
all mortals on deadlines and we have to
jump on opportunities before the windows
close
in back to the future marty is
constantly rushing to beat that clock
that bolt of lightning
striking the clock tower is an eternal
deadline and that anxiety
induces panic attacks throughout the
film especially as marty struggles to
start the delorean
despite arguably even higher stakes than
in games saving half the population of
the freaking universe the stakes don't
feel nearly as high is there really any
rush during the time heist like think
about it if cap
didn't beat younger cap what would have
stopped him from just tracking down the
scepter later on and zipping it back to
the present even when stark loses the
tesseract it's not an all-is-lost moment
they just think for five seconds and
then decide to jump back to an earlier
historical period
proving that they can just get unlimited
amounts of pin particles and try again
and again and again now one potential
ticking clock element is introduced 2014
thanos rises up to what they're doing
but he doesn't catch up with him until
after the time heist is completed he
only exists to give the avengers another
meaner thanos to fight in the climax
but you know what that battle is all we
really want from the finale to the
infinity saga and i gotta hand it to the
in-game team for people who weren't
really that interested in time travel
they did deliver
a pretty solid execution of it is end
game the best time travel movie
no it's not trying to be though but it
is one of the best crossover finales and
callback highlight reels
time travel was a means to that end and
perhaps
instead of seeing scott lang's line as
the riders throwing down the gauntlet to
time heist the title of best time travel
movie maybe they were simply hanging a
lantern
on their frustration that their time
travel mechanics would never
top the best of the future is a bunch of
[ __ ]
[Music]
you